welcome back we're just getting warmed
up so stick with us new light is being
cast on the FBI's efforts to investigate
the Trump campaign John Solomon's latest
piece in the hill newspaper details
internal bureau memos about the pressure
applied to Justice Department
investigators and their effort to get a
warrant on former Trump campaign adviser
Carter Page an email exchange between
infamous FBI agent Peter struck and his
lover Lisa Paige from October 14th of
2016 just a few weeks before the
election shows their desire to create
talking points for then FBI deputy
director Andrew Andy McCabe to help
secure that warrant one email from
struck reads in part and I quote at
minimum that keeps the hurry the F up
pressure on mccabe and believe it or not
that is just the tip of the iceberg
joining us now with reaction is tom
Fitton the president of judicial watch
Tom thanks for joining us this morning
we buried the lead on this one I'm gonna
put another quote up from Peter struck
this is from September 26th of 2016 he
said and as a pretense a this and I
quote at a minimum the letter the letter
that that Carter page wrote provides us
a pretext to interview him pretext is
code for an excuse to interview Carter
page how explosive is all this oh it's
further confirmation that the Trump
Russian investigation was infected by
this hyper political bias against
President Trump whether you're looking
for excuses to target his team you had
Paige write a letter complaining about
an improper FBI leak and the response
from one of the top FBI officials well
let's use as an excuse to bring him in
and interview him and then they follow
that up with the infamous FISA warrants
which were supported which would never
been approved but for their reliance on
the Clinton DNC dossier and then another
aspect of this which is also in
Solomon's piece is that right after the
election they are talking about this
after the election President Trump
selected they focus on what we have to
get all the people tied to Paul Matt
for it and compare notes and figure out
what we're going to do there well they
so Paul Manafort
is being targeted not because of
anything he did wrong but the trigger is
president Trump's election Paul Manafort
by the way right now is in solitary
confinement yes you know President Trump
should really think about ordering his
Justice Department that at least shut
this baller investigation down or a
posit given all the corruption in its
formation in the FBI in 2000 you're
referring to an email from structu page
where they said we need all of their
names to scrub and we should give them
ours for the same purposes scrubbing at
the election never a good look Carter
page was actually on this network a
couple of hours ago on Tucker's program
speaking for himself listen to what
quarter-page said do you expect that
you're going to be charged with anything
after all of this Tucker I couldn't even
imagine anything that I could
potentially be charged with it's just
you know particularly after seeing john
solomon's article today it just becomes
you know the whole you know that using
the term from that quote you had pretext
the pretext was absolutely outrageous
ridiculous so they found a pretext
then they surveil the guy for a year
that doesn't that sounds like a guy that
seems pretty confident they didn't find
anything this was a was this indeed the
witch-hunt the president accuses her
page was a cooperating informant with
the FBI and struck knew that that's why
they used the phrase pretext and the
spying on carter page was a convenient
vehicle to get at the Trump operation
and who knows what other FISA warrants
and applications were corruptly sent
over to the court as well Carter page
isn't going to be prosecuted
there is no Russia collusion and the oh
the occlusion that we're aware of with
respect to Russia is Hillary Clinton
using a fusion GPS to gather Russia
intelligence to smear Donald Trump
Muller ought to be investigating how his
investigation started if he's looking
for Russia collusion Tom help us for a
second though according the most recent
statement of expenditures Muller's
operation is ramping up what what does
that say to you oh well there are no
controls over molar practically speaking
not only does he have all of these other
lawyers
she's hired all of which are registered
Democrats know we're just Republicans
he's actually going into the Justice
Department and as needed using other
resources informally so that budget is
just a pretend number because the
Justice Department's at Muller's
beck-and-call an ANA control
investigation that is really abusive in
its targeting and of not only President
Trump with people around them wow I love
I don't know about you but I love
pretend numbers they're my favorite tom
Fitton thank you very much for your time
hey welcome you got